as well as the scramble to try and find
survivors there's a Scramble for
information to understand what's
happening across the disaster area so
the aid can go into the right place and
that they know how to do it because a
lot of roads might not be accessible but
that information is coming out
especially when we come to satellite
imagery we know there had been clouds
and storms which have made it hard but
we're starting to understand what's
happening better this is from Turkey I
want to show you some before and after
satellite pictures pay attention to this
strip of green here and the other thing
I'll just mark it for you pay attention
to this building too and what you'll see
if we just move it on is that building
has been completely demolished in the
earthquake but we've also had all these
tents appear here as part of that rescue
that search and rescue effort that
reconstruction effort we'll take you on
a bit more this is in the same town uh
this isn't a destruction so don't worry
about looking for that but just look at
these fields again and you'll see what's
happened is basically a tent Army there
these are all Aid Personnel trying to
get that Aid to where it's needed now
getting it to where it's needed you need
information for that and this is from
the UN this is a map where they've been
mapping some of the damage we can take
you into one town you'll understand the
sort of things they're looking at so
here we are at one time the red is
really severely damaged the Orange is
partially damaged yellow it's just a bit
damaged but if you're an aid worker
looking at that you can see well look
this is in the center of town built up
areas this is what we're going to need
to do the sort of supplies the sort of
equipment we're going to need that means
you're going into that zone a lot better
equipped than we would be if you didn't
have that information the next bit it
becomes how do you get there the
logistics of it this is another map I
want to show you uh this is from the
world food program and this is how they
coordinate logistics for all sorts of
Aid not just food you can see the green
roads are possible you can get in there
we've got airports over here so that one
is open to all traffic with priority for
eight flights this is only open to Aid
flights and ambulance this airport down
here is closed so that might be tricky
especially since that road is closed too
then you can combine that with some
seismic seismic information this shows
what was happening and here we have the
epicenter so that information becomes
really really useful now you'll notice
there isn't as much information down
here for Syria that's simply not there
as part of this map but it doesn't mean
we don't know exactly what's happening
there or if we can't build up a picture
at least of what's happening there
because the UN has warned that Syria uh
just might not doesn't have the capacity
of turkey to respond to such a
humanitarian crisis even if the numbers
are lower but we can find information
from surprising places this is actually
from Snapchat uh the social media app
you might have on your phone this is a
map of public posts and we go through
this we can see actually they've been
post over the last few days uh public
post about Sarah this is one in the
north of the country uh let's just show
you a bit bigger there we can see and
this is the white helmets we've talked
about them before they are volunteer
exercise and they help people trapped in
the rubble this is a video from Hussein
who spoken to many of his relatives were
killed in the earthquake they're already
refugees from the Syrian Civil War but
this is another means of communication
of information that information is so
vital the first three days after a
disaster are the most important time for
finding people it becomes a lot more
difficult after that information like
all of this Maps like all of this
improves the chances of finding people
alive